what better way to start the month of
Halloween than with a man who dresses up
like a skeleton bird Elden Rings Raven
Mountain assassin is a bloody finger who
puts on his deathbird costume to go hunt
down and unalive his tarnished Brethren
and just like the Dark Knight he wishes
he was he's mysterious we only get to
see the Assassin when we invade his
world with Europe and there is only one
item set that references him is his
cosplay Gear with such little
information he makes a prime candidate
for Elden Ring's most enigmatic tarnish
making him perfect for some lore hunting
in our investigation we will find
connections between this evil Batman and
some obscure death lore things like the
Earth trees past the eclipse the helfin
and of course the deathbirds Raven
Mountaineer more than most modern day
furries or convention goers desperately
wants to be a deathbird and we'll
explore that and all his other ties in
this video If this kind of lower
sleuthine is your thing feel free to
subscribe to the channel especially
since most of you watching my videos
keep coming back for more but you aren't
subscribed pressing that button helps
support the channel quite a lot and if
you're coming back to the channel
regularly anyways it makes that easier
with that let's delve as deep as we can
into the lore of Elden Ring's spooky is
tarnished the Assassin of Raven man guy
dresses up like a crow clearly has
issues despite sounding like a Hogwarts
rival school to Raya lucaria The Raven
man order is not something we find in
game there is just the one assassin and
considering we invade his world at the
main Academy gate maybe there is some
animosity between the Academy of Mages
and the Assassin school either that or
Darth Batman is just a Relentless PVP or
who like most players uses the main gate
as a makeshift Arena because we invade
him with Yura Hunter of bloody fingers
we know that that's what Raven Mount is
a bloody finger and from zuli's NPC
unmasking video we get to see that he
even has a Mogan Dynasty tattoo on his
forehead showing some allegiance to the
bloodlord but as evidenced by the name
the Raven Mountain assassin has a
different Master we also see it in his
clothing and fighting style but we get
to read about it explicitly from his
armor the Raptor set whereas the boots
and Greaves are just the base Bandit
gear characteristic Elden ring asset
reuse the chess piece and mask offer
some lore the sick gloomy cloak is the
Raptor's black feathers and it reads
robe crafted with the black feathers of
a bird of prey worn by the Assassins of
Raven map a ritual Implement for
transforming into a death bird if only
by imitation strengthens jump attacks we
are birds of prey Bringers of death we
see from this that despite fextra's
claims of a singular assassin named
Raven Mount there is actually some group
or order of these fellows and we learn
from the claw Talisman that the
Assassins of Raven Mount are killers by
trade they assail their victims while
dressed as Birds of Prey so it is a
group whose assassinations form some
basis of work but as even the Talisman
notes it does not just work because they
really don't need to dress up like birds
to kill people no there is something
more as seen from their desire to
imitate and become the deathbirds it
seems these assassins Revere these
creatures and they kill as part of their
emulation of the birds we see in the ash
of War they use the Raptor of The Mists
that they succeed in this to some degree
it reads duck into a low stance
momentarily Vanishing if an enemy attack
connects avian Wings will allow for a
quick Escape into the air the Assassins
have their own ritual in which they
embody a death bird gaining some
bird-like power through the process we
learn a little bit more about the act
from their headpiece the skeletal mask
which reads skeletal mask that tightly
grips the face worn by the Assassins of
Raven map this ritual Implement
relentlessly digs into the wearer's face
preserving one's human instincts while
dressed in Imitation of the deathbirds
perhaps their ritual turns them somewhat
feral or mindless like that of an animal
or a bird The Mask then keeps them sane
and of somewhat sound mind likely
through the intense pain of it you know
digging into their face this allows them
to remember their mission of death in
which they utilize the Raptor Talons
their qualic weapon of choice it reads
wielded by the Assassins of Raven map
this weapon allows them to imitate the
attacks of death Birds besides excelling
at Airborne attacks its charge attack
mimics The Vicious swoop of a bird of
prey
with nearly every object referencing the
imitation we can't go any further
without discussing the object of the
Raven Mount Obsession the deathbirds
there was a lot to talk about with these
birds and their powered up Brethren the
death right Birds Smoketown recently did
a great video on them and their ghost
flame which I highly recommend you check
out I'll give the summarized version
here we read from explosive ghost flame
that it is a sorcery of the Servants of
death in the time when there was no ERD
tree death was burned in ghost plane
death birds were the keepers of that
fire and we read from death's poker that
it is a barbed Rod carried by death
Birds the birds are graveyard fire
Keepers it is said that they rake out
the Ashen remains of the dead from their
Kilns starting to sound a bit like the
opening of Dark Souls 3. so the death
birds are a kind of force of death from
before the time of your tree they are
keepers of the ghost plane a fire with a
bitterly cold bite that was used in
times of old to burn the debt the ghost
flame torch tells us how the Fallen
Hawks were able to acquire ghost flame
by burning the bones of of their
comrades so all in all it is a signature
of primeval death in the lands between
before there was the herd tree with its
own practice of death and non-death
really the death Birds oversaw the
process through their use of the ghost
plane something that can rise out of
dead bones and burn death playing a role
in helping the spirits of the Dead move
along with the ERD trees ascendants the
deathbirds have been sidelined and
kicked out of their role as death
servants now they are only revered by
the Assassins of Raven map or the one
remaining assassin who wants to
revitalize the practice of the death
birds and their ritual the name of the
death right Birds the more powerful of
the two kinds and a few items reveal the
ritual behind the ghost flame and the
right of death the death ritual spear
reads ritual spear used by priests of
old who were permitted to come among the
deathbirds the priests became Guardians
of the birds Through The Rite of death
which also serves as an oath sworn to
their distant Resurrection these priests
can be seen in the wings of the death
rate Birds giving them power and waiting
for a future Resurrection here death is
described as a right telling us of a
ritual the deathbirds partoken as
keepers of the ghost plane there are
also The Feathered Branch swords red and
blue which state that they were once
used in ancient death rituals furthering
the reality of some ritual that it seems
to me the Raven mounts are trying to
revitalize each branch sword also has a
unique description with the red saying
the heart sings When one draws close to
death and a glorious end awaits those
who cling so tenaciously to life the
blue says the heart sings When one draws
close to death and thus does one cling
so tenaciously to life to render up a
death worth offering both states of
clinging to life and being close to
death would occur during the invasions
of the Assassins so they read to me as
further evidence that the goal of Raven
Mount is to rekindle the ancient death
ritual but as I said check out smoke for
a more in-depth deathbird look since
there's more unique to the Assassins
that I want to cover here unfortunately
we don't get much further info from our
22nd fight with them so let's look at
around where we find their armor the
Sage's cave to find quite a few morsels
of war first there is a Black Knight
assassin who drops the concealing Veil
which makes you invisible while
crouching these are thematically like
our subject hidden assassins and all but
there don't seem to be any tangible
connections if you know of any dear
viewer let me know in the comments
however there is another boss in the
cave Necromancer Garris a man wearing
the sage set and the Cave's namesake the
set tells us that it is attire of the
wise sages who were deemed heretical
evidence that the wearer was driven from
town we can see why Garris was exiled in
his name and his weapon family heads the
description of the bulbs at the end of
the foil reads the heads were made to
resemble those of his wife and two
children and even more the weapon's
unique skill familial Rancor reads
gently rattle the Copperheads to summon
vengeful spirits that chase down foes
the anguish of a spouse and children
invites a cursed wrath and between the
rancor name and the visual design of the
attack we can see that it uses ghost
plane well I don't know of any more
specific connections to the Raven mounts
it makes sense that Garris a
practitioner of ghost flame would have
some Association birds of a feather am I
right
but there's one more Connection in the
cave and it really opens up a big can of
worms in a chest we can come across the
candle tree wooden shield and ostensibly
playing Shield but all is not as it
seems The Shield's design and
description reveal a more Sinister side
it reads a tall medium-sized wooden
Shield light for its size and easy to
handle thought to represent a
surreptitious prophecy of cardinal sin
the lit candle tree design was forbidden
the white color and blue background May
mean to evoke the ghost plane but beyond
that the implications of what this
Shield might depict are varied and they
require us to look at a few other
obscure lore elements about death in the
lands between fortunately our great
community of lore Hunters has already
done much of the legwork the tarnished
archaeologist has a video on the
potential first burning of the archery
crunchy has a video on the healthin and
vlimit has one on the eclipse I'll look
at each of these ideas in turn because
they're all candidates for the candle
tree's depiction first the design is
described as a surreptitious prophecy of
card ordinal sin and the only other
thing that gets referred to in game as a
cardinal sin is the burning of the earth
tree which gets the special distinction
of first cardinal sin when we burn the
air Tree in game it burns red with the
flame of ruin this is also referred to
as a prophecy by a few flame
incantations but from the evidence shown
in the tarnished archaeologist's video
it seems like the Earth tree already
burned once before Ash fills the capital
city of Langdale when we first arrive
and the houses are sealed with wax
likely to prevent this ash from getting
in the gold Visage of the earth tree
also covers a small husk of what may be
the original tree pre-arson you can
check out ta's video for even more
evidence of this kind perhaps the herd
tree was once burned with ghost flame
the death Birds could have attacked the
tree to try to Stave off its Conquest
trying to hold on to their role and
ritual of death this is large
speculation to be sure but it would
provide further context for the Raven
Mountain assassins to oppose the herd
tree and hunt down the tarnished tour
led by its Grace so burning archery is
candidate one next we have a more
picture-perfect depiction instead of
symbolically looking like an earth tree
perhaps The Candle Tree Shield is
depicting something tangible we come
across in game candle trees we can find
around the lanes between we find these
as interaction points to meet an old
codger who will very slowly show you to
a cave or something otherwise cool their
visual design and coloring make them
look quite like the shield but if this
is the case then how do we explain the
item description well we know that the
light connects us with the spirit so
there's a connection to death and we
might see a further connection if we
explore the healthpen and obscurity
covered well by crunchy in his video on
the topic the health bin is referenced
by one item only the health and steeple
which just so happens to be dropped by a
tibia Mariner in the Mountaintop of the
Giants right next to a deathrite bird
its description reads Greatsword
patterned after the black steeple of the
helfin the lamp wood which guides the
dead of the spirit world the Lamplight
is similar to Grace in appearance only
it is is said that it can only be seen
by those who met their death in battle
the terms lampwood and Lamplight make me
think of something not too different
from the candle trees which serve some
guide the dead purpose as noted by some
user I forget the name of in the Elden
ring Discord we tarnished have met our
deaths in battle so that explains why we
can see them but to reel it back in a
bit the candle trees only have candles
no proper lamps like those we can find
on the tibia Mariners and crunchy
concludes that these candle trees are
not the lamp wood because they are not
colored black which the health and
steeple is stated to be these are fair
issues to bring up that may complicate
the picture but I think the connections
we see to the deathrite birds and the
Raven Mountain assassins could
strengthen the case perhaps the steeple
is black but the candle trees don't
appear to be because we are not dead in
a spirit world or dependent on them for
guidance if these trees were the lamp
wood then the helfin and the guidance of
the Dead could be tied to the ritual of
the deathbirds then the Raven Mountain
assassin's efforts would be related as
well since they are trying to revitalize
the death bird ritual in any case the
Helfman is an interesting and enigmatic
section of Elden Ring's lore and you
should really check out crunchy's video
to learn more and see why I'm probably
wrong with this speculation now there is
one more possibility and this works off
the candle trees too but instead of the
Ethereal ones and the healthin we're
going to look at real ones and the
failed Eclipse as I said V limit has a
great video on the eclipse so feel free
to watch that for some extra context we
can find a real example of our candle
trees and they'll fail I don't know how
you pronounce I'll fail it's the same
model but it's a real tangible item here
and we can even find some statues of
Nikola holding a candlebra of similar
design in his video V limit charts a
connection between mikalok Godwin and
the eclipse most explicitly there is a
spirit in Castle Soul who says Lord
mikola forgive me the sun has not been
swallowed our prayers were lacking your
comrade remains soulless I will never
set my eyes upon it now Your Divine
halleck tree velim explains a lot about
what the eclipse is and what it entails
but for our purposes it's enough to say
that it was something hoped for by
mikola to bring about some proper death
of Godwin and other unnamed demigods we
see that he had such a desire from the
golden Epitaph which reads O Brother
Lord Brother please die a true death the
prophecy of cardinal sin could be a
reference to the eclipse because there
are lots of connections the walking
mausoleums may be designed to avoid the
fate of Godwin and the skulls on their
feet reveal ghost flame
the mausoleum Knights have connection
with the death Birds their armor reads
the wing-shaped ornaments on its back
evoke the deathbird a self-inflicted
curse that ties the spirits of these
loyal Knights to the land having
willingly beheaded themselves so that
they may serve their masters in death
the eclipse may have allowed Godwin and
the unnamed demigods to properly die and
that in turn might have constituted a
return of the old death right for a bit
of extra speculation here there is also
the sacrificial acts which reads Hatchet
used in ancient sacrificial Rite a death
bird is depicted as a malevolent deity
the power of the right yet lingers a
small amount of FP is restored upon
slaying a foe firstly the depiction of
the death bird here seems to be of an
alive bird so maybe long ago the death
birds were normal looking birds not the
decrepit skeletons we find them in game
but more importantly this ax could have
been what was used to sever the heads of
the mausoleum Knights and the soulless
demigods this is speculation but
considering that the ax was used in some
beheadings long ago May maybe in the
right of death for the deathbird priests
and how it says that some of its power
still lingers I could see it being used
for a more recent death ritual too so as
the upshot of this Eclipse connection
perhaps The Raven Mountain assassins
have some Allegiance with mikola maybe
if they were a mightier Force we would
have seen them in game as a group aiding
mikola in attempts to usher in the
eclipse an effort to restore the status
and rights of the deathbirds if that
were the case there would be one more
question we'd have to ask since they
bear a tattoo of Moog do they know what
Moog has done to mikola though they
might not care seeing mikola as a tool
to achieve the ends of the death Birds
the only thing they really seem to care
about which of these theories might be
true some of them all of them or none of
them is hard to say for certain
unsurprisingly for lore in this game
feel free to let me know in the comments
which seems most likely to you and be
sure to say if there are any relevant
death connections I missed what we can
definitely say is that the world of
death seems to often go against the
erdry now it's surprising when its order
sealed away destined death the Raven
Mountain assassin we find at Raya
lucaria is okay with that heresy and
probably most others considering he has
a Mong tattoo on his face at the end
it's too bad we never see him actually
invade anything not to mention any other
members of his assassin order going
around the lands between the Colleen and
the death bird imitation with that we
have covered I think what there is to
say about the lone Raven Mountain
assassin that we see for like 25 seconds
in game did a pretty good job of
stretching that out if you've enjoyed
the video then consider subscribing to
the channel or becoming a patron on
patreon I'll be doing more lore and more
spooky deep Dives up until Halloween my
poll showed interest in the Halloween
hands of Riley lucaria so I'll cover
them to some degree next I hope you
enjoyed the video and a final thanks for
watching hope to see you in the next one
bye